or a description of a molecule or really anything else we have in mind, and there's some computational task
being performed on that input alone.
The key point here is
that the entire input is provided to the computation, and nothing about the
input is hidden from it.
The query model of
computation works differently.
In the query model, the input is made available
in the form of a function which the computation can
access by making queries,
or in other words, by evaluating the function
on different inputs.
Here you can see that represented
in the form of a picture.
Similar to what we had before, the computation is represented
by a blue rectangle, but instead of receiving an input directly
in the form of a string
of bits, for instance, it accesses the input by effectively asking questions
and receiving answers.
We sometimes use the
terms oracle and black box to refer to the mechanism
that provides the input.
There is a distinction between
an oracle and a black box in complexity theory, but that won't be relevant at all for the purposes of this discussion.
Anyway, these terms are meant
to convey the basic idea.
In ancient Greece, you
could go to an oracle, like the Oracle at Delphi,
and ask an important question,
and the oracle would answer
that specific question, but she certainly wouldn't tell you everything that she knew.
Along similar lines, when
we think about a black box, we have in mind some
sort of process or system
where we can choose what goes in and we can see what comes out, but we don't have any understanding
of its inner workings.
And that's the case here. The input to the problem
takes the form of a function, and all that we can do is
to evaluate that function,
but otherwise, we don't have
any knowledge or understanding of how it works.
Throughout the lesson,
we'll reserve the letter f for the function that
represents the input, and we'll make the assumption
that it always takes the
form that you see right here.
Sigma denotes the binary alphabet, so f is a function from strings
of bits to strings of bits,
and specifically, we'll
assume that the input to f is a string of bits having length n, and the output is a string
of bits having length m,
where n and m are positive integers.
For different problems, we'll
have restrictions on n and m, but in all cases, the input function will
take a form like this.
When we say that a
computation makes a query, what we mean is that the
function f is evaluated once,
that is, some string x of length N is selected by the computation, and the string f of x is
then made available to it
by the oracle or the black box. And finally, the very simple way that we'll measure the computational cost
of a query algorithm is to count how many queries it requires.
So, although it is true that
we are really most interested in how long computations take, when we study the query model,
we generally keep things
simple and just count queries, and that's what we will do in this lesson.
Now, let's take a look at a
few examples of query problems, meaning computational
problems in the query model,
and here, by the way, I'm just gonna describe
the problems themselves, and at this point, I won't say anything
about how to solve them.
The first problem is the OR problem.
In this case, the input is a function
from n bits to just 1 bit, so m is equal to 1 for this problem,
and the required output for
the problem is either 1 or 0.
If there is some n bits string x for which f of x is equal to 1, then the correct answer is 1,
and otherwise, if f of x is
always 0 for every string x, then the correct answer is 0.
So if we think about the function f as providing us with random
access to two to the n bits, one for each n bit string x,
then what the it's asking
for is the OR of those bits, and that's why it's called the OR problem.
Another example is the parity problem, which is similar to the OR problem except that asks for the parity,
or in other words, the eXclusive OR of all of the single-bit
output values of the function.
Another way to say that is
that the correct answer is 0 if the number of n bits strings x for which f of x is equal to 1 is even,
and the correct answer is
1 if that number is odd.
An example of a problem where m is not necessarily equal to 1 is the minimum problem.
Here, the function f takes the usual form, and there are no restrictions on n and m,
and the correct answer is whatever output value
of the function comes first in the lexicographic
or dictionary ordering
of binary strings. Alternatively, if you wanna
think about strings of length m as representing non-negative
integers in binary notation,
then the correct answer
is the smallest possible or minimum value that
comes out of this function.